the jurogan experience what is it like
to be you like what is it like to
and then i know you know you've gone
through a lot of [ __ ]
and this latest thing with uh getting
off of the benzodiazepine
that to me was a real shocker because
first of all i had no idea that you were
taking it and then to find out that it's
that difficult to get off of and then to
hear from other people that have tried
to get off of it how difficult it is and
then to realize how many people around
me have an issue with that stuff
xanax is a [ __ ] it and i didn't
know what a [ __ ] it was until i
talked to a friend who is a counselor at
a drug rehab center where he was saying
that that is one of the ways that people
get locked back into drinking and doing
drugs is a psychiatrist will prescribe
xanax and sober people who get on xanax
all of a sudden start drinking he said
it's super common
he said that it's one of the most
difficult drugs to get off of he said
and this is something that uh dr carl
hart who's uh i love him to death he's
brilliant he he speaks so openly and
honestly about drugs and you know this
guy's a professor at columbia he said
that there's two drugs that will kill
you when you get off of them he goes
it's alcohol and benzodiazepine those
are the two that if you just quit you'll
[ __ ] die
and or you wish you would meanwhile
they're handing those things out like
tic tacs yeah well they were regarded as
a safe substitute for barbiturates and
you could easily overdose on
barbiturates especially with alcohol
when did they know when did they know
when was it in the literature the
difficulty of
detoxing yourself from these
very recently really yeah jesus christ
and when did they start being handed out
20 years ago [ __ ]
more so what happened people just stayed
on them
often
my i have one good friend that takes it
every day and takes it oftentimes with
alcohol which i know you're absolutely
not supposed to do there's not a damn
thing i can do about it i this is a
friend that i love to death and i just
go i put my hands up and i go it's not
not gonna do
and he's been on it for more than ten
years yeah well i started taking them
because i was ill yeah you know and it
they helped because i couldn't sleep i
couldn't sleep at all i don't know
i don't know
what i still really don't know what
happened you couldn't sleep and so
an anti-anxiety medication do you think
that any this is the one one of the
things that i want to talk to you about
it's really why i brought up the fame
thing
how much of
the pressure
of being attacked by all these different
people and having these um people write
these
horrible articles about you and
i know you read that stuff which is
different from me i don't read stuff
about me and i think that's helped me
tremendously and that like my gauge of
how i deal with people is like tucker
carlson doesn't read things about him
either
he could dull you can tell by the way he
communicates he seems free you know
there's a burden that people carry
around when they read things about
themselves like eric weinstein has that
burden sometimes
you know when people read yeah well part
of the reason so did i read things about
me well yeah but
that wasn't what was stressful exactly
although it was there's what it's
a multitude of things when i first got
i've had a history of depression and
that runs in my family and that's
probably stems back for me right to the
time when i was a kid
and and i think when i really got sick
in 2016 it was partly a manifestation of
that
but at the time my job was threatened
like actually yeah and my clinical
practice was threatened
and the canadian revenue agency was
after me all at the same time and they
were after me because of a mistake they
made which they admitted three months
later and the college was after me
because of a vindictive client who came
after me with a pack of lies but because
they were so and basically i
emerged
from that unscathed but that was by no
means obvious that that was going to be
the case i was accused of sexual
misconduct and the evidence
when i was dealing with this client i
would turn my wedding ring around
you'd spin it well i play with it right
and that was sexual misconduct yeah well
to her it was a signal of some dark
underlying desire that i wasn't that was
polluting our therapeutic relationship
i've been doing that with you the whole
conversation yeah i have this uh silicon
wedding ring yeah i'm going to report
i'd report you if you're in there i'd
yeah exactly
yes well there you go it's it's really
bad and if there was a college that
governed the behavior of reprobates like
you i would definitely report no don't
do that that's terrible i stretch it out
oh that's
freudian to the extreme although i don't
know what turning it means how could
stretching a silicone wedding band be
freudian well you're putting your finger
in the little rubber [ __ ] kind of
vaginas you're dealing with rubber is
you know that's good anyways we don't
have to go there so that was all you had
done was turn play with your wedding
ring yeah yeah and then i was really i
really helped her a lot like well
unfortunately when you're dealing with
people that are extremely troubled the
oftentimes they look for external
reasons why they're troubled and they
find oppressors well she was also angry
with me because when all this blew up
around me it interfered with my clinical
practice and she had come to rely on our
weekly meetings oh yeah so she was she
was angry about being abandoned and it
was really sad because i didn't want to
abandon my clients but
i had to stop my clinical practice which
was also very upsetting to me because i
had like 20 clients and i knew these
people man like they were i knew these
people yeah you know i'd fold them
through thick and thin and then all of a
sudden so many things piled up around me
that i found when i was in a clinical
session that i was distracted
so you can't be distracted in the
clinical session right
and so anyways what emerged from that
and it was in the middle of the winter
and i have seasonal affective disorder i
couldn't sleep
and at all for quite a long time and i
went to my doctor and i said i can't
sleep and he gave me a sleeping
medication and and an anti-anxiety drug
and i took the a little bit of the
anti-anxiety drug and i could sleep and
my life was pretty stressful and i
thought okay i'm much better i'm just
going to leave this be this is working
i'm not going to muck with it because i
could barely go back to work and what
was it a low dose yeah yeah i couldn't
even
really
so it alleviated the anxiety but it
didn't affect your cognitive performance
or it didn't affect the well it didn't
affect it as much as how sick i was like
that really affected so sick meaning
depressed no no when you say you're sick
no no i uh
when it hit
um
i if i stood up my blood pressure was
really low if i stood up i'd faint i was
fainting five or six times a day when
are we talking about 2016. okay so this
is when all the pressure from all these
different sources was coming at you yeah
and that was making you sick
so it was changing physically yeah that
was part of it i think i think what it
did was it it stressed me enough so that
i was susceptible more susceptible to
whatever was wrong with me in the first
place so there's a lot of immunological
problems how long did it take you to
recover from the benzos
well when i finally
two years
and and i haven't fully recovered but
but but also i was also sick no i have
my left hand is quite numb
and was way more numb both my hands both
hands and my feet were like completely
numb
and uh i was in like excruciating pain
for
two years like pain at levels that i
didn't even know was possible all the
time or no on occasion no this is one of
the things that was terrible about it is
that it was really really bad in the
morning and did it start right after you
got off of the nox no but it got way
worse
so it just started showing up eventually
yeah and then it started to get worse
about the same time that tammy went into
the hospital but when because she was
fighting her way through
you know catastrophic cancer at the same
time when this started down so this was
additional stress
yes and that heightened everything well
it didn't it certainly didn't help right
i think it made me again it made me more
susceptible to something that was
already happening
so whatever this illness has that that's
plagued my family my father my
grandfather multiple cousins and and a
lot of immunological problems on my
mother's side too my one i had a cousin
whose daughter died of immunological
problems the same ones that michaela had
and this is all mitigated somehow or
another by this only eating meat i don't
know it certainly is for michaela and
for you well i don't know that for sure
i know what the diet has done